[Music]
hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast
special mid-week
live stream number 87 if i am
correct in my accounting you are correct
i am correct
um all right we have a lot planned for
today
i know many people are interested to see
what we have to say about the collette
article that was published before we get
to that let us talk announcements
announcements we are streaming on both
youtube and odyssey today we encourage
everyone to go to the odyssey
stream if you have the capacity to and
if it's if it's working well for you
um but because uh in large part what we
are doing today is responding to
a critique such as it was uh we
feel uh a little bit generous um
we feel that this is actually keeping
within the
community guidelines such as they are
yes the preposterous community
guidelines
but nonetheless so that's that's what
we're doing
um we do encourage you to subscribe
to both to all four of our channels
actually our main channel brett
weinstein
um on both youtube and odyssey and the
dark horse podcast clips channel on both
on both places um you can find stuff
that we've got like those goliath
t-shirts we introduced last
week at store.darkhorsepodcast.org
um you can ask questions now for the
live q a's that follow
uh shortly after we finish these main
live streams by going to
darkhorsesubmissions.com there should be
a link
in the video description here and that
allows us not to go through youtube and
have them take their predatory
cut i don't even know if we'd make any
money now since we're still demonetized
there
but that allows us to go that way and um
also allows you a few more features
please consider joining uh one or both
of our patreons you get darkhorse
membership at mine which
offers you uh access to a once monthly
two-hour private q a where the numbers
are small enough that we get to interact
with the people in chat
we never see the chat during these live
streams of course and uh
and brett has two uh smaller
conversations with uh with patrons um
at some higher dollar amounts on his uh
we don't have any ads today
and um we are going to be yes we are
going to be
uh rebutting that cool article and
providing
some of the evidence that uh we feel
like they
either left out we we know that they
either left out
or uh woefully misconstrued in what they
wrote
and uh we might have time to talk about
a few other little things
around covet such as a new paper out
about uh underlying conditions which is
a
drum i've been beating a lot the the
idea that actually
uh just because you're in an age group
uh that seems like it's at high risk
does not mean that your fate is sealed
if you can do something about your
health
in advance of getting exposed trying to
get exposed and if you do get exposed
anything that you can do to be maximally
healthy actually
directly affects outcomes from covid and
of course a wide variety of other
diseases as well
and then in keeping with what has now
become our pattern we are now in week
five
of reading an excerpt from our
forthcoming book every week we started
with the introduction
we're now on chapter 4 which just
happens to be the chapter called
medicine
so we are going to finish with a short
excerpt from the chapter on medicine
which
many of you will not be surprised to
hear is actually completely coincident
with the kinds of arguments we've been
making on this live stream
and that we are going to be making here
today isn't that fortuitous
isn't that for two of us all right so
let me let's place this in context and
let me first say something
to people who perhaps have not read the
article in colette it is not necessary
that you have read that article this
should be
a very logical live stream to follow you
can always go back and read
that article if you want to understand
exactly what we were responding to but
our hope here is not to go point by
point
in fact i should say that the reason
that this live stream is not happening
on a saturday
is that i was traveling and i have not
been home for 24 consecutive hours since
before the quillette article was
published so there is going to be a
written response
to the collat article it is not going to
be emerging today
but asap but
what we are going to do here is try to
um place these arguments in
a context where their actual logical
implication will be
unmistakable and when you see the errors
that have been made
in that colette article and then you
correct them in your mind you will see
logically where one
has to end up on these essential
questions so that's what you're looking
for
is we're going to show you what they've
done incorrectly
on a couple of very central points and
then once you see what correct logic
suggests
you will understand why we are somewhere
very different in this pandemic
than most would have you believe all
right i want to start though
with something unrelated to
covid pandemic treatments anything of
that nature and it goes back to
something
that i realized in high school i
realized in high school
my family as your family had
rules very strict rules about television
it was understood back in the 70s and
80s
that there was something not very good
for you about television and therefore
families like ours put limits on what
you could watch but there were also
exceptions
to those limits in our household and i
assume in your household there was an
exception for public broadcasting
for example so you know we watched a lot
of pbs documentaries and things like
that
uh sometimes the news hour but in any
case
what this caused me to realize was that
although people talked about it they
would literally use phrases like the
idiot box
but the problem was it's it's the it's
not the box
it's the business model and i actually
started using that phrase to myself it's
not the box it's the business model
and it's not the box it's the business
model actually was born out
at the point that hbo started delivering
high quality uh novel content and it
turned out that the audience wasn't
foolish and that it would be
very interested in seeing long-form
content of a high quality which we've
all now become familiar with so what i
want to say is
it's not the box it's the business model
is an important recognition that there
are lots of things
that come at us in one form or another
and depending upon
the form we should look at them very
differently and in fact you can see the
same thing
with respect to our cell phones our cell
phones are capable of doing marvelous
things letting you navigate some city
you don't know as if you were native to
it
but we also all recognize that these
things are designed to be
addictive and to keep us doing things
that aren't necessarily good for us so
again
it's not the box it's the business model
that's what makes your cell phone so
dangerous to you
you can make the same argument for
pornography
i consider myself very sex positive i
like sex
right who doesn't on the other hand when
you look at what comes at you through
porn that is uh very misinformative
about what sexual behavior is actually
like and in fact it's misinformative in
a way
that is targeted at getting people to
become addicted to the content to look
at
this producer's content rather than that
produces in other words it's part of an
economic competition
in which you are actually the product um
you're
sitting through these things buying them
presumably is
the the targeted behavior so that that
is not an indictment of erotic content
it is an indictment of the business
model that delivers porn
right and so again not the box it's the
business model and the point that i'm
trying to make here
is that we see the same dynamic playing
out now
with the vaccines and pharmaceuticals
that we are being told that we must
take and the point is
it is reasonable to understand
vaccines and pharmaceuticals as
useful tools in improving and protecting
human health but there is something
about the business model that is
delivering these things now that ought
to cause even those of us
who are cautiously welcoming of these
things to look
with some skepticism at the current
versions because the business models are
in fact
um quite remarkable and not dissimilar
from what has happened to our phones
and our um and our our televisions
so um in our household that is this
household here
you and i are ordinarily
pretty enthusiastic about vaccination
and we're actually
uh pretty skeptical of synthetic pills
and there's a reason for this there's a
logical reason
and the reason is that vaccines that is
to say the original versions of vaccines
are a very elegant mechanism for doing
something
that is clearly tremendously beneficial
for health right the way a vaccine
typically works is it provides an
advanced
warning to the immune system of a
pathogen it has not yet seen so it
doesn't have to learn the formula for
fighting that pathogen
when it encounters the disease it can
learn it in advance and then fend off
the disease the way you would fend off a
disease you had already had
that's very as a minimal intervention
very elegant
and basically the point is most of what
it is is your own endogenous ability
to learn the formula of some hostile
agent and to do so well so that's a
you're providing information to a system
that you already have on board
right it's a little bit like a a wanted
poster that you might mail to a post
office in some town that hasn't yet seen
this criminal
right it's a it's an advanced warning
very elegant and
return on investment has been
spectacular for humanity so
i will say i have personally lectured
many times to my classes on not only the
way vaccines work
but on the history of vaccines and
there's the you know the western edward
jenner story and there's also other
stories from around the world where
other
uh populations have discovered the same
property and have
have used it so i am proudly
enthusiastic about the idea
of vaccines and that shows in my
pedagogical history
um you wrote a sentence into our book
two years ago
you do you happen to have it on hand um
let me see i didn't know you were gonna
call me up on that um well while you
were looking i'll say what the
the sentence is you wrote a sentence um
that was pointing out this
uh very same thing so from your
perspective you were arguing
um that vaccines are in fact a
tremendous um
boon to human health yeah this is
something you know again i just
i happened to be prepared to be tweeting
this this week this sentence
uh from exactly the same chapter we'll
be reading from at the end of this
episode
even the great victories of western
medicine surgery antibiotics and
vaccines
have been over extrapolated applied
where they shouldn't be when all you
have is a knife a pill and a shot
the whole world looks as though it would
benefit from being cut and medicated
all right and the flip side of this is
in our family we
actually have a kind of concern about
pharmaceuticals very generally and this
arises from the fact that in my graduate
work as many of you who
are longtime fans of the podcast will
know
my graduate work i happened onto what i
believe
is a flaw in the drug safety system i
published this flaw
and the flaw basically amounts to the
mice that are
often used for things like drug safety
testing and other experiments having
been
accidentally evolutionarily modified by
the breeding protocol
that is used to produce them so that
their telomeres which are these
repetitive sequences at the ends of
chromosomes have been elongated
tremendously and this
has potentially very large impacts
effectively these animals have a
capacity to repair their tissues so that
if you poison them
but you don't outright kill them they
actually have an extremely good capacity
to fix themselves whereas we have a
limited capacity so they're
they're bad models now that has caused
us
over the many years that that work was
published in 2002
in the many years since you and i have a
kind of uneasy relationship when we open
the medicine cabinet because we know
that
virtually every drug in there was tested
against
mice that are very very capable of
dealing with toxicity
and so we don't know and there are lots
of instances in which
drugs have shown themselves to be toxic
after they were proven or
proven safe in safety testing so vioxx
fenfin
gleevec seldane erythromycin all of the
nsaids all of these
drugs have been shown to be hazardous at
one level or another
so ordinarily in this household we are
very pro-vaccine
and we are a bit skeptical of pills a
lot skeptical
a lot skeptical of pills because we know
that even if you know that the hazard is
there you don't know which pills it
applies to and in what way
all right this situation
that is to say the coveted pandemic has
put the shoe
on the other foot that is to say in this
case we find ourselves quite skeptical
of these
vaccines and we find ourselves actually
favorably
looking upon a pill
and the reason for that is that in this
case we are not dealing
with classic vaccines that function in
that super elegant way
we're dealing with vaccines that are
actually extremely novel
now they are very promising this is an
amazing interesting platform the
mrna vaccines in particular the
adenovector
dna vaccine these are things that
potentially if we can figure out how to
do this
well and safely are potentially a huge
boon to humanity but at the moment we're
dealing
with brand new technologies and they are
brand new technologies
that have in multiple ways shown
themselves not to function the way their
designers had intended
as we've discussed on the podcast before
the vaccines don't stay at the injection
site in the way they are hoped
the spike protein on which they are
based
is toxic and the spike protein which was
modified which was designed by those who
made the vaccines to stick
in the cell membrane and to remain there
for the immune system to see it
and respond to it in many cases breaks
free and floats around the body
that's three turns out there's another
apparent
design failure that we've seen zach
could you put up the
nature paper on the dosage
so this is a just emerging i think it's
july
9th nature article that says
that the moderna vaccine is actually
functional in terms of generating an
immune response at a quarter
the dose so to whatever extent there
might be risk involved
with the vaccine potentially it could
have been greatly
reduced by just diminishing the amount
of uh of the active ingredients
well so this is the first time i'm
seeing this the subtitle of this news
it's it's a news article within the
scientific journal nature
the subtitle of which is results hint
that dose stretching could help to
address the world's acute vaccine
shortage
um it seems to me that results hint that
does stretching
could also help to address any side
effects
of of the application of this vaccine as
well and it's
it's actually a classic if you think
about it that presentation
flips the obvious interpretation on its
head
and turns it into a silver lining but
without going through the
oops maybe people have been getting more
of this and they need phase
but in any case so what we know is that
these vaccines are remarkable
we also know that they do not function
as intended in multiple regards and that
ought to have us being very cautious
with respect to things like
the signal that they are not doing uh
what they are hoped to do
with all that said it is also the case
that the perverse incentives
are worse than normal in this
circumstance so that is to say under
normal circumstances
there are incentives that work in the
public's interest in other words a
pharmaceutical company has an interest
in producing a product that's really
very good because a product that's
really very good
will cause doctors to prescribe it and
patients to get it and it will cause
credit to go to the company and all of
that that's a good incentive but a
perverse incentive is one where the
company's interest is not
necessarily in the interests of the
patient
or society and so anyway there are
unusual
perverse incentives here for one thing
we like it or not have a big emerging
market
covet is causing lots and lots of
problems and both epidemiologically
and with respect to the well-being of
patients
there's a lot of new stuff to be done
and so
that big emerging market may look a
different way
to a company that may be able to exploit
it profitably
than it does to society that might like
to shut down that big emerging market do
we know what effect that has we don't
but it is a question worth asking
we are also in a crisis mentality
because of the
severe impact of covet on planet earth
that crisis mentality affects the way
people think they may not be as
clear-headed about what's really in
their interest
and most conspicuously we've got
immunity from liability
which is we don't well these companies
that make the
vaccines have immunity from liability so
to the extent that one of the things
that aligns the incentives of
patients with producers of
pharmaceuticals
is the threat that if a pharmaceutical
isn't good for you that they will get
sued to the extent that that has been
taken off the table that obviously
creates
an increase in the hazard to patients
that companies won't take those risks
seriously enough and at the same time
the perverse incentives on the one side
are greater than normal
we also have the best drug
available and maybe it's even two drugs
which we will get back to but
the best drug available um seems to be
safer than normal because it isn't new
and it's been administered
so many times that we actually know a
lot about its impact on people so to the
extent that there might be flaws in the
drug safety system or
whatever it is we have a huge amount of
data on what happens
in actual human patients and
i would also point out this is no it's
not an absolute protection but the fact
that the drug in question ivermectin
comes from uh soil bacteria it's not a
completely synthetic
molecule means that it is likely to be
similar to things that one's ancestors
have encountered before and there's
therefore
a good chance that the body has a
reasonably elegant way of dealing with
it rather than
uh using some mechanism that's that's
not so great
okay there are lots of exceptions to
that of course but
um all else being equal uh trust the
thing from
nature sooner than the thing from lab
understanding that
sometimes nature is indeed exactly out
to kill you yes right
cyanide for example is a natural product
that is a very good
non-competitive inhibitor of respiratory
enzymes and
uh very frightening for that reason okay
so all that said we now need to address
the content of the quillette article by
yuri degen and claire berlinsky
and the way to understand this is to
take something that i've been saying
various different places those who have
watched the podcast before will almost
certainly have heard me say it before
but to really put it in context
it is unfortunate for us that ivermectin
is
one drug and the reason that it's
unfortunate is because it has two
different impacts and one needs to be
very
good something that the colette article
was not at all but the
one needs to be very good at separating
whether one is talking about
the prophylactic impact that means its
ability to present
uh to prevent the contraction of of
covid19
versus the treatment that is to say
alleviating the symptoms
and interestingly we see the same
phenomenon on the vaccine side where
very often we will be told
the vaccines are highly effective and
then when one talks about the fact that
they are imperfect that's a technical
term
then uh we the fallback position is yes
but they are excellent at preventing
hospitalization and death which they may
well be but the point is
preventing people from contracting the
disease is a very different phenomenon
than alleviating the worst symptoms of
the disease and it's a very different
language than people use about normal
vaccines
yes sterilizing immunity is the standard
that without knowing those terms
most people assume when they hear about
vaccination and
it seems that these vaccines do not meet
that standard
at least as well as we would hope right
which has impacts on a question that we
are going to argue is
the central question inescapably once
you have seen it
it is admittedly a bit obscure until you
do but um let us get there
and in fact we're there the issue is
this
we have two branches of a decision tree
we have two
branches we can go down one branch we
can go down the other branch and they
lead to very different worlds
okay the world you're talking about now
yes we collectively humanity
humanity could drive sars kovi v2
to extinction all right now if we drive
sarsko v2 to extinction
then the amount of loss gargantuan as it
has been
is finite it will come to an end right
in the same way
that it has for sars kobe one or
sars cove but stars cov1 it's extinct as
far as we know
and the point is that is a desirable
goal
because it means no further harm comes
and it means that the amount of harm is
therefore calculable
if we do not drive sars kov2 to
extinction
the amount of harm that comes in the
form of
years of life lost health degraded
and human suffering both of those left
behind when someone dies and the
suffering of those who contract the
disease
is incalculable if if this becomes a
permanent fellow traveler if this
becomes endemic to humanity
then anybody can realize well actually
there's no way to calculate
how much the cost of this virus will be
to humans it's indefinitely large
and so our argument is and has been
we must put everything we can into
driving sars kobe 2
to extinction it is possible that we
can't get there
but we have to try and in fact this
isn't even just about
us the current living people of earth
this is about us doing
what we must do our obligation to future
people of earth
so that they don't have to be dealing
with the consequences of this virus
right two different worlds and the
question is if we can drive sars kobe 2
to extinction we have an obligation
to do everything in our power to make
that happen because the costs are so
very large if we fail
to do it okay so
sorry i've lost my place
so there is some conflict of interest
therefore
potentially between cures
and treatments or prophylactics that are
highly effective
and treatments and i would ask people to
run themselves through a thought
experiment
what do people imagine will happen when
the fiduciary responsibility
of a pharmaceutical corporation is in
conflict
with patient well-being
or with public health or both it's a
simple question fiduciary responsibility
is
a legal fact these the people who run
these corporations have a fiduciary
responsibility to their shareholders
that is different than them having a
moral responsibility
to their patients and that is different
still
from the moral obligation that they have
to humanity
those who live and those who will
ultimately live and the point is
there is no magic formula by which these
things all align so you have to ask
yourself the question
what do you expect somebody in a
position of power
or some group in a position of power the
board of directors inside one of these
corporations
what do you expect it to do when its
shareholders interests are in conflict
with the interests of its patients or
of humanity and humanity and its
patients are not synonymous here
because realize there are many people on
earth who are not within reach of these
vaccines and so
they may be infected with sars kobe 2
down the line because of some decision
made
inside of a corporation so they are not
patients if they are not touched by the
product of the corporation but they do
suffer consequences of how we behave if
we for example
fumble the ball and sars kobe 2 remains
circulating around planet earth then all
the people who
come down with it in the future are
actually victims of our bad choosing
and so we have to work very hard not to
do that and i think the thought
experiment if you do it honestly you
will realize that there is a genuine
problem
there is inherently no synonymy between
patient well-being and shareholder
well-being because shareholder
well-being is a financial matter
and we all understand all adults know
that there are times
when one makes money at the expense of
other people so we've seen that many
times and we've seen it pharmaceutically
frequently
and just just to rephrase slightly
this requires neither evil nor
conspiracy to be true
that's not precluding the possibility of
evil or conspiracy but it certainly
doesn't require either thing
there is simply a conflict of fiduciary
interest
potentially which will have
um will potentially force
corporations hands so to speak
metaphorical hands
into making decisions that are bad for
all the rest of us
yeah in fact um i think it was 2012
i gave a tedx talk called the personal
responsibility vortex
and i would call people's attention i
did a little section in there
i worked with uh an artist former
student of our steve bilsma
and basically the idea was if you do a
thought experiment and you have three
types of corporations at the beginning
of the thought experiment
one type will do the right thing
irrespective of its effect on
profitability one of them will do the
profitable thing irrespective of the
harm
that flows from it and then some third
category is more realistic it's some
balance between
uh focus on profit and uh limit on what
the corporation is willing to do and you
start iterating
the competition between these things you
find the do-gooder corporation goes
extinct
and you find that the corporation that
is
balanced at the beginning of this
experiment actually evolves towards
ruthlessness in order to compete with
the corporation that always does the
most profitable thing
under the business model that does not
restrict the behavior of said
corporations
exactly right in a totally unregulated
market this is what will happen
right a totally unregulated market now
astute observers will be thinking but
this isn't a totally unregulated market
and that's where we're going to end up
talking about regulatory capture but we
will return we will return to that
um let us just say in this case
we can recognize that at least in
principle
somebody looking at if let's imagine
you're not even in the pharmaceutical
industry you're just trying to imagine
what
what these investments might be worth
the pharmaceutical industry might be
worth a very different amount
in light of a permanent crisis one that
was
constantly producing opportunities to
address
the next version of covid as the
pandemic evolves right then if
the pandemic were to come to an end as a
result of wise policy and
high quality pharmaceuticals or whatever
else okay that's just a simple fact it
might be true
that the industry is worth a very
different amount in those you know down
the two different branches of the
decision tree
and so i would remind people
that economically speaking it is
unfortunately viable
for an entity a corporation or an
industry
to destroy trillions in the pursuit of
billions
and that is something that we those
whose
well-being will be destroyed in such a
process must
counteract we must recognize that that
can happen and we must not let it happen
so anyway that's a that's a hazard
okay um
so in light of the fact
that we have this thought experiment
maybe let's look
briefly into the question of what
is happening in the environment in which
we sort out
how we are to behave the academic
environment in which the papers are
produced the regulatory environment
and we happen to have uh a
marvelous artifact here yeah an artifact
also known as a book a book
[Laughter]
bad pharma how drug companies mislead
doctors and harm patients
by ben goldacre who's a medical doctor
and i should say some of you will be
familiar with ben goldacre from a ted
talk that he gave
called i think it is called what doctors
don't know about the drugs they
prescribe
anyway it's a very good ted talk
recommend it so this is an extraordinary
book
uh it's a terrifying book and it's from
2013.
uh and i'm just going to read a
paragraph from the introduction
so to be clear this whole book is about
meticulously defending every assertion
in the paragraph that follows
drugs are tested by the people who
manufacture them in poorly designed
trials on hopelessly small numbers of
weird unrepresentative patients
and analyzed using techniques which are
flawed by design in such a way that they
exaggerate the benefits of treatments
unsurprisingly these trials tend to
produce results that favor the
manufacturer
when trials throw up results the
companies don't like they are perfectly
entitled to hide them from doctors and
patients
so we only ever see a distorted picture
of any drug's true effects
regulators see most of the trial data
but only from early on in a drug's life
and even then they don't give this data
to doctors or patients or even to other
parts of government
this distorted evidence is then
communicated and applied in a distorted
fashion
in their 40 years of practice after
leaving medical school doctors hear
about what works through ad hoc oral
traditions
from sales reps colleagues or journals
but those colleagues can be in the pay
of drug companies often undisclosed
and the journals are too and so are the
patient groups
and finally academic papers which
everyone thinks of as objective
are often covertly planned and written
by people who work directly for the
companies
without disclosure sometimes whole
academic journals are even owned
outright by one drug company
aside from all this for several of the
most important enduring problems in
medicine
we have no idea what the best treatment
is because it is not in anyone's
financial interest to conduct any trials
at all
these are ongoing problems and although
people have claimed to fix many of them
for the most part they have failed so
all these problems persist but worse
than ever because now people can pretend
that everything is fine
after all what is the publication date
on that
2013. 2013 so this is
uh six plus years prior to covert 19.
now that's that's a description of the
normal state
the current state well the the the new
normal as of 2013.
yes the unfortunate new normal state as
of 2013.
in this case we have extra elements and
you have to ask yourself
what will their effect be on what sounds
like the normal corruption of the
regulatory
and academic structures surrounding
pharmaceuticals yeah and it's it's those
two things so you know
savvy people will have said and i've
seen many responses
um to you know two you know incredulous
claims i think there's a conspiracy
going on
and like i said none of this precludes
the possibility of a conspiracy but it
requires none and so people we we will
say and others will say regulatory
capture
it is well known well documented
ubiquitous
but what people talk about less is the
academic capture
which is part of the regulatory capture
and is you know very well documented
there we've been talking about since
we've been these live streams and
it's part of why we are critical of
things like the peer review process
even though the process itself
is is in place precisely to allow
only the best research to get through
but of course it doesn't always work
like that
often doesn't yes it doesn't and you
know let's put it this way that you
could arrange
a peer review that would work but a
blind peer review like this
is destined to fail it is destined to be
abused
um so anyway we can we can return to
that another time but
in any case we have uh regulatory
capture which is
uh pretty well known people have heard
that term academic capture
which may be a new term and people are
not nearly so aware that it is happening
and what appears to be well actually and
just just one side point you know i
think um
because of the way that we became public
figures
it is it has been imagined and even by
many people who
um who we are we are friends with and we
see eye to eye on a lot of things
that the part of academia that has gone
astray
is only over in fill in the blank
studies and you know in grievance
studies spaces
and in you know the rise of
administrators who don't know anything
and you know creation of lots of those
positions and all and that all
is true and deeply problematic and we're
seeing the downstream effects of all of
that
spread out into the media and the
schools and the government and all of
this is true
but we have been talking about for much
longer in fact
then we were focused on the problem with
effectively the downstream effects of
postmodernism in academia
the problem of the money in big science
which is something that we talked about
a few
livestream episodes ago and that
academic capture
effectively in which you have these
unholy alliances
between either the government granting
agencies or the corporate granting
agencies
such that you have alliances that create
perverse incentives to only produce some
results
is skewing not just what we think to be
true but how
well people can actually think and that
combination means that the vast majority
of people out there
are not given data with which to assess
things and weren't given educations
with which they could then use to assess
what they don't know yes
and uh crucially here so we've seen
capture go from the narrow regulatory to
increased
academic basically a steering of
what looks to the outside like high
quality thought
right so you get false consensus around
things that aren't true
but we are also seeing quite predictably
if you think about it we are also seeing
the steering of the public conversation
why because the public conversation
threatens to
reveal the problem if the academic
conversation
can't then the public conversation can
reveal the corruption of the academic
conversation
etc and that's a serious problem so what
we are seeing are
um organized campaigns to
uh intervene in public discussions and
even more disturbingly
we are seeing the platforms participate
in this by
hard coding into their community
guidelines for example
what evidence you can report on right if
you if if the evidence says
x and you have to report on the faulty
conclusion why
more positively in order to even mention
that x has
been demonstrated that's obvious that's
that's like
the social media platforms intervening
in
you know sense-making itself so that's
that's certainly true
um but i think the the point that i was
trying to make which ties it back to
this uh dagan and berlinski and dagon
piece and quill at this last week
is the number of places in that article
that are journalistically or
scientifically simply just
flat out wrong is extraordinary and
the the journalistic stuff just like the
basic fact checking with regard to who's
who and when what happened and who said
what
um you know would shouldn't have passed
like high school journalism
yeah the science and we're not going to
do any of that today and we haven't even
written it really
at all into the um into the piece that
we're writing either because
um it's just i i think it's just not
worth our time but it certainly
shouldn't have should have been worth
the authors and the editors and the
publishers time
because that's irresponsible at the very
least the scientific
errors are extraordinary at a level that
i wasn't expecting
um you know we as as has been said uh
uh on twitter we need better skeptics
all of us do but we do
you know we we need we need people to
push back with integrity
and rigor and honor and care
and you know we probably won't get
through most of most of these today and
a lot of them will be in the written
response that aren't what we talk about
today but the number of times that they
cite a paper that then actually says
either not at all what they said or
actually the opposite
is extraordinary and you know that's
actually what peer review is for so
where were their peers here so we are
acting like their peers by giving them
the pushback that they um that
apparently
no one on you know team vaccinate
everyone
is on is giving them why not why
are are none of those people's peers
capable i doubt it
so why aren't they speaking so
i don't know whether we should even be
down this road at all
but here's the problem i know i don't
know
claire berlinsky at all she showed up on
my radar when she requested
uh would i respond to some responsible
counter-arguments and i said yes because
she approached in what seemed like
good faith and then she immediately uh
behaved unethically
three times in a row so i don't know
whether this is
that she's blinded by what she thinks is
at stake in the vaccines or this is the
way she normally behaves but
i just can't say in yuri dagan's case
it's different
i've interacted with yuri dagen and i
believe yuri dagan is highly capable
and that frankly he's done the world of
service
over in the lab leak hypothesis space
right his work was excellent there and
so the fact of somebody who is capable
of
excellent work like that doing work that
is this bad and we are
not going to go point by point because i
think everything would get lost if we
did for one thing
heather and i i was out of town but uh
on the first night after the thing
emerged we went through it and it
was virtually every paragraph had at
least one major flaw in it
but nonetheless we don't need to do that
in order for you to see
how bad the quality of arguments are
and if you were to go through just even
the factual claims of who said what and
where it was said the
number of errors is staggering given the
amount of text
all right so let us move on to the core
issue that we are going to focus on and
as we've said we are going to separate
cleanly
the issue of prophylaxis that is the
prevention of the contraction of covid
from the issue of treatment um
uh can i i know you are have places
you're going but i think this actually
may be a place to mention
that the authors of the the
article don't seem to know what
prophylaxis means
uh may i yeah please yeah so um
somewhere and it's lowered down in the
in the written part of
so here we go um this is just a pair
just one paragraph from
their the collette piece how does the
evidence for the prophylactic efficacy
of ivermectin stack up against the
vaccines it's not even close
remember we don't yet know that the drug
provides any significant benefit
a high quality study published in jama
found that in a randomized clinical
trial that included 476 patients with
mild cover 19
quote a five-day course of ivermectin
compared with placebo did not
significantly improve the time to
resolution of symptoms
this is this is their paragraph about
the prophylactic efficacy of ivermectin
and the study they cite is about
treatment prophylaxis and treatment are
different
and if you actually don't even know that
you have no
business critiquing arguments which are
looking at the literature and using
evolutionary
theory and logic and careful analysis
to assess what the benefits might be if
you can't even tell the difference
between prophylaxis and treatment yes so
they
absolutely screw up and somehow it got
through the editing process they screw
up that
that fundamental distinction what's more
they cherry pick and they use a study
that uses
time to resolution of symptoms as a
measure now
it's hard to imagine a more noisy
measure because
think about the last time you had a cold
and
ask yourself how you would nail down the
exact moment at which it was completely
gone
right that's a very difficult
calculation to do because of the way
these things get better right you feel
80 better
um but in any case so let us go to the
um the issue that we are going to argue
is
absolutely central that they have
completely botched and having botched it
when you see how the logic correctly
works you'll understand
why their entire argument must be wrong
okay so this
surrounds the argentina
study by uh hector cavallo
cardinal carvajal uh and several other
authors so carrio at all
and in this study um there were
approximately there were 1200
you want to describe it yeah uh so there
was a there was a preliminary study
first
in which um there were i don't remember
what the numbers were but uh not very
many healthcare workers and
and uh and they put them into
into groups people self-selected into
groups um this is neither
uh this is you know far from blind um
and they gave
uh some of them a dose
of a regular dosage of ivermectin and
carrageenan
and those were four times a day and some
of them none and everyone had ppe
everyone had personal protective
equipment on them uh and the results
were so staggeringly
promising with regard to the ivermatt
and carrageenan city that they then did
the bigger study
which had 1195 healthcare workers in
argentina
in which 788 about two-thirds of them
were put on this combination of
ivermectin and carrageenan
uh difference being in the main study
and 1195 people study
the ivermectin was a weekly dose it's
actually exactly the same
uh protocol that the flccc has has put
up as it what is it called the
imath math plus protocol i think it's
like two migs per kilogram body weight
two milligrams point two milligrams per
kilogram body weight um
okay i'm not i don't i'm not sure about
that um
and they were then there's they've got
four major hospitals argentina
and they've still given the carrageenan
four times daily the ivermectin once a
week
and what did they find they found from
each of those four hospitals combining
their 1195 total healthcare workers
of the two-thirds of them who were on
the ivermectin and carrageenan as
prophylaxis
not a single person came down with coven
and of those not
on the prophylaxis which again included
ivermectin carrageenan
58 or 237 of that 407
got sick so that is an amazing result
an amazing result uh but what we haven't
explained what carrageenan is
and um both for completeness and because
it's charming i think we need to
target is it charming oh it's true well
think about it this way
i mean forgive the aside but carrageenan
is a derivative
of seaweed it is actually widely used in
a
great many products it's like a
thickener and a lot of processed foods
and stuff but it also turns out to have
some antiviral properties which are
pretty interesting
um anyway it's i think it's charming
because
by the way i i i don't know that this is
a very serious topic and this is a
little bit ironic but
um ivermectin is derived from a soil
bacterium
discovered by a japanese scientist in
japanese soil
and the fact that it is being delivered
with seaweed kind of
um suggests that it's like an ivermectin
roll or something like that
no i thought you were going to say
carrageenan was discovered by like an
orca
sauce but in any case
um so what you've got is a seaweed
derivative and
ivermectin being delivered in the
preliminary study they're being
the iberometanus being delivered uh four
times a day or something
and in the final study the larger study
it's being delivered once a week
at the standard dosage recommended by
the flccc
um okay now
what did berlinsky and dagon do with
this and i know that this is dagon
because degan deployed this argument on
me when i
talked to him about this privately long
before um he and berlinsky
teamed up on this and so he deployed the
same crazy argument on me and i told him
it was wrong then but
um zach can you put up that little
section
of the pdf with the highlighted um
okay can you put it where we can see it
what is this is it is this a card of oil
paper this is
degan and berlinsky talking about
what their reaction to this prophylactic
uh iron mechanical study is and
what they say what yuri says is does
this
pass the smell test that not a single
person who got treated with ivermectin
and carrageenans
uh came down with kovid and he says
not at all in the initial phase of the
study the workers
who received ivermectin were dosed every
four hours for two weeks
we are asked to believe that none of
these workers
tested positive for sars kovi ii the
virus that causes covid19
during this two-week period we are also
asked to accept
that none tested positive during the
three weeks that followed
now this is not a scientific argument in
fact if this were true
that would be amazing but because we
already know that amazing can't happen
this can't be true right this is the
this is
two two problems here one as i believe
i've heard richard dawkins say
incredulity is not an argument yuri
dagan i think i think his actual framing
is failure of imagination failure is not
an argument
failure of imagination is not an
argument um and so
what we have here is as you point out
the result is extraordinary and
therefore it is to be disbelieved
therefore it is not evidence
right now without any without any
exploration
of what might have gone wrong in the
protocol that could possibly have
produced this result now
degen has gone in two different
directions here
in this paper that they published he
appears to be alleging
fraud doesn't use the word no but but
does this pass the spell test we are
asked to believe
we are asked to accept we are actually
what it sounds like who are we asking an
accusation of fraud yeah
who are we asked to believe this by by
the authors of the study and i would
actually encourage you we will post a
link
to the study and i would ask you to go
look at it the
the uh methods are very clear and
dagen's point is we are asked to believe
by these authors
that these were the results and his
claim is they can't possibly be because
they're too good
which is not an argument at all and to
claire layman i would point
out this appears to be
a libel that you are publishing
the allegation that this is fraud
without the a shred of evidence that
that is what is going on
now on twitter degan went a different
direction
uh zach could you put up his uh i sent
you
his tweet in which he takes me to task
for
what he says is blinding me
okay he says yes at brett weinstein the
numbers are fooling you
because the numbers come from a study
that didn't control for patient and
researcher bias
patients knew they were taking
ivermectin
as did the researchers and the results
show a
clear bias that's why proper studies are
double blind he says now first of all
proper studies aren't double blind
double blind is an excellent thing when
you have the ability to do it
um because it does control for one kind
of bias on the other hand
yuri degen where he has backed away from
what he did in
uh he and berlinsky's paper where they
appear to be alleging fraud
here appears to be alleging the placebo
effect
now zach would you put up before you do
let me just say
um yuri dagan appears to be suffering
from a
common misconception about the placebo
effect
many people believe that we are capable
of simply healing if we believe we have
been treated with something effective
for the condition that we have
now i've been interested in this
phenomenon since i was a freshman in
college in fact i wrote a paper on the
placebo effect back then i'm not sure
how good a paper it was but i've been
interested in the placebo effect ever
since
for the following reason it doesn't make
any sense
that this would be the case because
evolutionarily speaking
health is the product of natural
selection arranging
for homeostasis right when that begins
to fail
we are diseased and if it were simply
true that all you had to do was
believe yourself to be getting better in
order to get better then
surely selection would have triggered
that without you actually needing to
take a pill or have a sham surgery or
something like that right
so it has always struck me as very odd
that we make the claim that the placebo
effect is highly effective in curing
people and
in digging what one finds is in fact it
isn't
zach you want to put up uh actually to
show uh heather's screen
so here so this is a paper published in
the new england new england journal of
medicine in 2001
and there are more since then called the
plus is the placebo powerless an
analysis of clinical trials comparing
placebo with no treatment
and just to go right to the the punch
line in the conclusions what i've got
highlighted here
although placebos had no significant
effect on objective or binary outcomes
they had possible small benefits in
studies with continuous subjective
outcomes
and for the treatment of pain that is
um mind over mind perhaps but not mind
over matter
right and you know this makes perfect
sense for one thing we are all familiar
with the fact
that um if you injure yourself in the
middle of an emergency
you may not be able to detect that you
are injured until the emergency has
passed and this evolutionarily makes
makes perfect sense because
you may need to continue to do things
and the fact that you may have broken
your wrist
should be no obstacle to you doing what
you need to do next in order to get out
of the burning building or whatever
whatever it is so of course pain pain
is an adaptation and that means that
there are times when it's not good for
you to feel it and there are
mechanisms that can turn it down and
then there are times when you really
need to pay attention to it so you can
heal
or you can learn the lesson of what you
did wrong and then it can be turned up
so
it makes sense that it would be
modulatable and it therefore
is not preposterous that it could be
modulated by your impression that you
had taken a positive step but
let me just say so uh in the past and my
uh students will remember lectures on
this topic
the point is what doesn't change with
placebo
are objective measures like
did it take longer for you to die of the
cancer that you had
right those measures don't change
because if those things were simply
changeable by state of mind
they would be changed by state of mind
before you ever got around to anybody
deciding to medically trick you
selection would have gotten there
selection would have done and i mean in
fact health sort of is it does
it does whatever it can to make you
functional so in any case
let's just um there will be those
who will say ah but that's not what
degan is saying in that in that tweet
he's he's arguing that you know all else
being equal double blind
is better right all else being equal uh
but so you know what is the risk of
having a non-blinded study in which the
participants know what which group
they're in either treatment or control
um there is a risk that um people will
behave differently knowing something
right and so what seems to be implied in
his
in in dagen's tweet at you
is that those people who are on
treatment will behave in other ways so
as to protect themselves from covet
and that could be true but i can equally
well see an argument going the other
direction
that those people who are not on the
treatment
um and no they're not would go out of
their way to
to avoid covid because they know they're
not on this treatment that had such
uh remarkable results in the preliminary
trial right so
i don't know which way to call that and
i wouldn't want to call it either way
frankly
but the idea that one of those is so
clearly the thing and therefore without
this being double blind you can't trust
any of it
no sorry although what i really think
that that that tweet is about
is is wiggling out from we were claiming
fraud because that
is what they were doing that is what
they were doing and um
we are not doctors we are also not
lawyers um
if i had published that i'd take it down
because i think uh
carvalho at all have cause to be quite
upset with you and
uh you have um you have defamed them
yeah
because i mean frankly we are asked to
believe has nothing to do with double
blind or not
yeah right we are asked to believe that
the language of berlin scandigan
is is regardless of
how you know what the methodology of
this study was we just don't think these
results are true
right absolutely and no matter what you
do right even if there was some
behavioral bias and i
i think the most likely thing in light
of the fact that people chose what group
to be in
based on the fact that the materials
that they were being given had shown
great promise in preventing covet is
that those people who felt they were
somewhat protected would be somewhat
less careful so it would go in exactly
the opposite direction but regardless
nothing gets you to a hundred percent
effect
other than an effect or you know fraud
for which there is zero evidence so
their allegation is out of place they
haven't you know they've been cowardly
and they haven't made it out loud but
nonetheless
it's uh it's a terrible quality argument
now they do make
one other argument that we're going to
engage um you want to put that uh
highlighted screenshot back up so
degan's other favorite argument here has
to do still with regard to this
argentina yes with regard to the uh the
argentina paper
is that it can't possibly have had this
effect and the way
yuri dagan knows that it can't possibly
have had this effect
is that the decay rate in the blood
of ivermectin is such that the number
is way below the threshold of yuri
degen's belief
for effectiveness right and so because
it falls below the degen threshold
yuri thinks that it can't have had this
effect on their physiology
right um but no i mean this is an
incredible argument because for one
thing
it rather assumes that yuri dagan knows
how it does or doesn't work
and his point is well if it works at the
beginning of the week when the levels
are high then it has dropped below the
threshold that where it could do
anything and people should be catching
covet at the end of the week
now the problem is a he hasn't
established anything about
how it works we don't know that it's the
plasma level
the pharmacokinetics are not obvious and
he clearly doesn't know that he doesn't
know them
i can probably come up with a dozen
mechanisms by which it might work that
have nothing to do with concentration i
would point out that for one thing
vaccines work
on a basis that circulating
concentration isn't
uh the mechanism it goes through the
immune system now i don't believe that
that's likely to be what's going on here
but
and there's abundant other evidence as
we'll get to with regard to ivermectin
against covid but
even more to the point with ivermectin
against all these other diseases it's a
disease that's effective against
in which the prophylactic regime is like
once every week or once every month
right and if the half-life of being you
know in the blood being 18
hours is the thing that matters how is
it working in all those other cases
right is it magically a different drug
in all those other cases no it's not
right it's the same drug
for one thing in this case we actually
know that it's fat soluble
right so it may be that it's decreased
in the blood because it's been absorbed
into
adipose tissue and it gets released on
possibilities but not our job to figure
it out not our job to figure it out but
anyway
that graph is very scientific looking i
will grant
your neighbors a very scientific looking
graph and it's a very scientific
sounding argument
and in any case yeah i mean it does use
some words that sound sciencey
yeah right exactly like half-life right
you know
um but anyway uh enough
razzing yuri dagan for his preposterous
argument um
but the point though the point of all of
this
is if it was let's say that there was
doubt about whether or not ivermectin
was effective as
a treatment for covid okay now i don't
believe
there is so much evidence from so many
different studies that it has some
effect and those studies vary a lot
their protocols
range from good to lousy in terms of
whether they treat early or late or all
of these things
but let's just say that there was no
evidence at all that it was an effective
treatment
but let's say that that study of the
argentine
argentine hospitals is accurate or
anywhere near accurate
right what that says is that we have a
tool that is actually capable of taking
us
down the decision tree that leads us to
the extinction
of this terrible pathogen right now that
i'm you know we don't know whether you
have raised issues of whether or not
compliance would be good enough to get
it
to extinction whether we could organize
people enough
that they could take it you know one
doesn't want to be on some
drug forever so you know is it possible
to get humanity organized enough to
you know to use this tool in a way that
it could actually bring this thing to
extinction
i don't know but the idea that you're
going to dismiss
the very evidence that suggests that's
possible
on the basis that the evidence is too
strong to be real
when you have you haven't pointed to
anything in the methodology that's wrong
all you've done is alluded to the fact
that the study doesn't take a form
that you think would have been best yeah
i would also one one last point
this obsession with randomized
controlled trials
right double blind randomized controlled
trials
it imagines that the double blindness of
them
is the only place where bias uh can be
and therefore the double blindness
excludes it but the point is there are
other places in studies
where uh you know for example the
researchers may not know which patients
have gotten
the drug in which patients were in the
control but they do understand the
purpose of the study
right they're not blind to the purpose
of the study and so to imagine that
these things are immune to bias is
preposterous
all right you were going to say well i
think
um we won't do nearly as much here as
we've written into what the written
rebel have but um i wanted to just say
three other things about the the record
of um the evidence for ivermectin as
prophylaxis
uh the only other thing that uh
berlinsky and dagen
invoke is the lowry meta-analysis
and again i'm not going to go through
all the arguments here
on the live stream but once it's out
we'll post the paper that we put out
um in in the show notes uh they
literally their entire takedown of this
meta-analysis
from uh it's actually bryant um but it's
often referred to as the lorry
meta-analysis so the entire takedown is
um that they cite another paper that
says that the larry met analysis is of
critically low quality
so i went and spent some time with that
other paper that reports that the
lowry met analysis of critically low
quality and my
admittedly uh non-professional opinion
is that that paper
is of critically low quality itself
it is a um it is a report never to be
peer reviewed not just you know it's a
pre-print not it's trying to find a
publication never
to be peer-reviewed effectively gray
literature put out by the scientific
advisory group
of the alberta health services who are
using a tool called the amstar ii
assessment with which i was previously
unfamiliar which is itself designed
not to generate an overall score and
it's designed for people who don't have
advanced training in epidemiology to
allow them to carry out rapid
assessments
and it is uh basically a tool
designed to be used for people to do
rapid assessments by non-experts not to
generate an overall score
and it is on their say-so again not
peer-reviewed in any way not expected to
be peer-reviewed
their assessment of the lowry
meta-analysis as being of critically low
quality
that degen and berlinsky have assessed
lowry's paper of being
critically low quality that's not
scientific in
any way and so you know they feel like
it's this killing blow
um the other killing blow perhaps being
that they have called laurie another of
larry's paper
phenomenally insane well this this
vitriol and sort of you know ad hominem
level attack
uh does not actually constitute either
evidence or argument
and when when i go back and look at the
lowry paper based on actually the kinds
of stuff that
amstar 2 was saying you know what should
you be thinking about you know yep
you know larry and all are very very
careful about saying that
there are only three papers that have
been looking at prophylaxis
for ivermectin ivermectin is prophylaxis
against cova that they thought were of
high enough quality to include
and they were concerned about the
quality of those papers but they did
include them and even so
came up with um whatever they came up
with
ivermectin prophylaxis reduced coping 19
infection by an average 86 percent with
a 95
confidence interval between 79 and 91
percent
uh so you know they acknowledge all the
flaws in the papers that they are
covering
and the critique the the the half-assed
critique from the alberta health
services
which is the only thing that degan and
berlinsky cite
doesn't actually go after the analysis
itself it just goes after the papers
in the analysis right and in fact uh
it's it's personal
phenomenally insane yeah which is again
you know a different paper of lorries
but
it's it's the point is it's beyond
unnecessary it's irresponsible
yes it's irresponsible and so let me
just um
further to the point because we've got a
lot more to cover and already an hour in
here
um but ivermectin is prophylaxis there's
at least two and i suspect more but at
least two
lines of evidence that don't show up
anywhere in that colette piece right
anywhere in the clappies
and we've talked about them before here
uh and then just
very very briefly remind our regular
viewers and listeners and points
both to the paper that we'll put out and
to our previous episodes we talked about
evidence out of africa
in episode 80 and out of india in
episode 83.
so basically the evidence out of africa
and there are two
yes peer-reviewed papers that
independently had this idea and went and
tested this hypothesis
that given that in africa there
are uh a lot of chemoprophylaxis regimes
in place that inc some of which include
ivermectin on a regular basis for
um for prevention of other diseases not
having anything to do with covid
it occurred to two different groups of
researchers to look at whether or not
covet rates
in countries that already have
chemoprophylaxis of ivermectin on
board in its people were lower than in
those countries in africa where
ivermectin was not part of the
chemoprophylactic regimen or they didn't
have any chemo
prophylactic regimen at all what did
they find yes they found exactly what
you
will be expecting here uh which is that
in those countries where people were
already on ivermectin for reasons having
nothing to do with covid
there are much lower rates of covet now
it's um
you know it doesn't satisfy any of the
like randomized controlled
control trials um specificities that we
are being asked to require and maybe
that's why it's ignored
but it's evidence and it's actually
really good evidence
and the other thing is the data that
we're seeing coming out of largely india
but um really this
um this
data analyst data scientist juan jaime
who's like you just show my screen very
briefly there's a whole lot here
at juan jaime's site
and give me my screen back for a minute
i'm going to show you just a few of what
of the things that he has revealed
so for instance um and these are these
are just uh
graphs that he's put up on on twitter
um here we go this is from july 9th
last 30 days utter pradesh with 17 of
the country population
this is these are two states in india uh
with 17 of the country population had
2.5
of the deaths and less than one percent
of the cases whereas
maharashtra with nine percent of the
population had 18 of the cases and 50
of the total deaths and uttara pradesh
is has an active aggressive ivermectin
campaign
and maharashtra and if i may zach have
my screen back here
maharashtra um does not but
interestingly so you know in summary
basically um the indian state with an
active ivermectin program had far fewer
cases and deaths than expected given its
population
and a state with a much less aggressive
ivermectin program and really not that
much at all
at that point had far more than was
expected given its population
but interestingly the state of
maharashtra has filed an
action with the mumbai high court to add
ivermectin and vitamin d
as prophylaxis for kovid and the high
court came back and said nope
ivermectin's already in there as
treatment therefore we're not going to
change the protocol
which again you know like not only
berlinsky and dagon
but the mumbai high court and you know
presumably people throughout the world
are confused about this really
fundamental difference
between treatment and prophylaxis and
it's killing people it's going to be
costing people's lives
so um there are a whole bunch of other
indian states where we see
um evidence so here's zach here's just
here's just one
this is um karnataka where
the for those just listening you see a
rise
in the coveted cases and um at the point
that ivermectin is introduced
um it is it is still climbing for a
little while but um
but it begins to come down so zach if
you can just sort of as soon as i put it
up just put it up for like five seconds
then take it down because i want to show
a bunch of these and this is just from
the paper so it's not
um clean this is utter khand
with again cases and fatalities
uh falling after um after the
introduction of vermectin
in goa we see the same
pattern and um
okay one more and then we also see
and i won't go through all of these but
it's not just in indian states either
we also see us the same thing that's not
coming up
right in panama and mexico let me see if
either of these are going to come up
neatly
um yeah oh um
yeah in mexico the evidence is is is the
same way so
that's just there's a lot of visuals to
show you all at once but again we'll
link to these
and why
why are why do we pay no attention to
these sorts of data the second the
second is a data analyst who is looking
at publicly available data
and putting it onto graphs and
most trained scientists aren't going to
think to go there
but in the case of the africa findings
those are those are out there in the
scientific literature
there are two papers there are two
peer-reviewed papers published in the
scientific literature finding
uh independently that in those countries
that already had
prophylaxis of ibrachten on board in its
population case rates of covet were
lower
okay why why no mention of that so what
we've got
is at least three different kinds of
evidence all pointing in the same
direction right
we've got the accidental fact of
basically a retrospective observation in
africa we've got uh afric we got
differences
in protocol between indian states
and we've got experimental tests in the
case of the
the argentina study for example yeah
right and well
and some actual um admittedly small
admittedly
imperfect studies that larry uses that
larry and company use
in their meta-analysis yep right so
that's four
okay so that's four different kinds of
evidence all pointing in the same
direction
now i want to try to put this into
context first of all
i think lots of smart people
are being lured by whatever
the pr campaign is here into thinking
they are being smart for insisting on
large-scale randomized controlled trials
now first of all
it's not that they are absent with
ivermectin they exist they have been
included in the meta-analysis
you can see what they say um but
people don't really understand the
nature of evidence there are many
different kinds of evidence
randomized controlled trials are one
kind of evidence but
this idea that nothing short of that
would justify giving
a very safe drug to a patient for which
there was no
alternative now again i'm talking about
treatment here but the idea
that you would need a randomized
controlled trial to intervene like that
is like
somebody would need to prove to you that
what's coming out of that hose is water
before you'd spray it on a burning
building
right it doesn't make sense and so
anyway i've been struggling with
how what is this attack in which
effectively
on you know when you have some product
that you don't want to talk about you
force some level of scientific
standard on it that will cause it to be
dismissed because the standard can't be
met
i would point out that one thing that is
true of these large-scale randomized
controlled trials is they're very very
expensive
so in fact by insisting on that kind of
evidence
you delay the process for a repurposed
drug in which there's not much profit to
be made
to establish that it can be used and you
probably
derail the effort because it might cost
20 million bucks to do
uh that study and so you know basically
it's a cryptic uh slant of the playing
field
in favor of novel high profit drugs
about which we know less
and against repurposed drugs about which
we know a lot
so that's a problem and anyway what's
the term for this i'm going to call it
mortal rigger the idea is you
apply a standard of rigor that is
arbitrarily high and the consequence
is um that people will not get the drugs
that they need because
um because the objective is to prevent
them from being discussed
mortal rigger rather than fatal rigor i
kind of like mortal rigger better but
anyway we can we can talk about the term
but
but i mean i think i i think
maybe you said it but maybe i missed
what to me is the punch line there which
is the double standard of the
of the standard of evidence that works
that will suffice right so
you know in in berlinski and dagon's
piece as
in other frankly pseudo-scientific
attempted takedowns
of any critique of vaccine safety
or any discussion of the potential
efficacy of ivermectinous prophylaxis
we see the vaccines held to impossibly
low standards
and ivermectin held to impossibly high
standards and
really your standards ought to stay the
same else they ain't standards
right outstanding standards and the fact
is we know very little about the
vaccines because they're so new
um i'm also told by dr malone that the
emergency use authorizations are
actually an alternative to another
process that would have caused data to
be
collected something called extended use
so instead of emergency use
authorization extended use
would effectively have enrolled
everybody who got vaccinated
into the trial so the data on what
happened to them would have been
collected and then we wouldn't have to
have arguments about
what the meaning of the data in the
verse system is because
everybody would have been included
effectively continuation of the phase
three
into into into now at least which
actually
is well it would have been great it
would have been great right and it's
obviously the right thing to do in light
of hey it's an emergency and we're going
to deploy some very new technology and
hopefully it works
wouldn't you want to know well it
depends i mean especially with
um a immunity from liability there are
at least
arguments that some people might not
want to know so
the last thing i want to say on this
before we move on to the next
is one has to think
there's a way and i think americans are
particularly guilty of this
where we tend to see america as the
world
right we tend to forget that the rest of
the world is out there now
the question is if you are comparing
something that appears to be
highly effective as a prophylactic
prevention of covid19
ivermectin and carrageenan right if you
are comparing that
to vaccines and you understand that you
are going to be living in one of two
worlds
downstream of this you're either going
to be living in a world in which we've
driven cyrus kobe 2 to extinction in
which case the harms from it are finite
or you're going to be living in a world
in which the harms continue to
accumulate for the rest of our lives
right and beyond you don't want to be
living in that second world
there is no mechanism whereby these
vaccines can produce that effect
right so the punchline of all of this i
believe
is you you haven't demonstrated that yet
so what do you mean by that well
okay how is it that we are going to a
these vaccines are imperfect and so we
which is a term of
art which is a technical term meaning
that meaning that
people get breakthrough cases people who
have been
immunized still get coveted and you know
so we're seeing this in places like
israel which has been surprisingly so
imperfect
that 95 number that we've heard
variously
at various times of these are 95
effective a perfect vaccine would be 100
right right would be 100 exactly so
the fact of these vaccines being
imperfect means that in some sense they
are setting the stage
for well okay which variants are
escaping
their detection the detection that they
induce in the immune system
and then those variants circulate and so
then there's a question about
booster shots which could update your
immunity and what is the cost of getting
repeated booster shots of this type
we don't know right so there's that that
they're imperfect and therefore they do
not create a landscape in which
you know if you vaccinate everybody
covet is driven from it
right and on the other and the other
thing is reaching the entire world we've
got a world of almost 8 billion people
in it and so
if your point was look these vaccines
are great
they work really wonderfully you should
still
if you're on team humanity you should
still be
wildly enthusiastic about using whatever
other tools we have for preventing
people from contracting covid because
the objective of this exercise is either
to drive it to extinction
or it isn't and the way to drive it to
extinction is to use the best tools you
have
clearly clearly ivermectin is one of
those tools why
it's cheap anybody can produce it you
can produce it in large quantities so
you can get it to the world
you can give it to people who won't or
can't take the vaccines so
the thing that ought to be bugging you
is why
does this come down to people who are
pro-vaccine enthusiastically pro-vaccine
being anti-ivermectin why are they not
both of those things at once
okay let's let's just talk briefly about
um the safety record of ivermectin
uh the short version is it's been in use
for decades
uh given to tens of millions probably
hundreds of millions of people at this
point i think that's absolutely 100 true
um and um and also widely used
veterinarily
and uh just has an extraordinary safety
record but
the uh the scaremongering and again
we're not going to
focus as much here today
um as as we will in writing on um
really the use of fear to drive
analytical conclusions that berlinsky
and dagon use
which is uh not just dishonest but but
dangerous
um but they they really do seem to be
fear-mongering
with regard to the safety record of
ivermectin and so they give three
examples they actually give
four but one of them is a is a one-off
some some poor
hapless woman took way too much um
you know and end up with liver toxicity
because of course you do when you take
way too much of really just about
anything
but so the three remaining um
instances that they provide of why we
actually shouldn't imagine that
ivermectin is that safe is they say it
causes testicular dysfunction
it's known to ratigen which means that
it um causes problems for fetuses during
pregnancy
during while while they're still in the
mom
and that it's been linked to serious
neurological adverse events
so to these particular claims uh let me
just say that the paper that they cite
for distinctive
testicular dysfunction um a it's in rats
it's not in humans
and they and the paper itself says
ivermectin and a carouside and
anti-helmetic drug of the family of
aerobactins
produced by streptomyces over matillus
cultures is a well tolerated drug with
no side effects in mammals at
pharmacological doses
now this is in the introduction of the
paper which
berlinsky and dagon are claiming is
finding testicular dysfunction and when
you actually read the paper you find
that there are
tiny effects maybe but it's in
combination with this other drug
verapamil
in which fertility meiotic effects
become an issue so that's cheating
that's not the result that they were
claiming uh
to the second paper uh which they cite
for the tragicity of the drug
um that paper actually finds the
opposite like
it's it's stunning like this this was
actually the point in
digging into their references where i i
almost threw up my hands in disbelief
i'm like
are they not even trying like you know
how how is it that you could possibly
cite a paper
that went looking for possible
tradogenic effects of ivermectin and
pregnancy because it's used
so widely as a prophylactic in so many
countries against so many things already
that we should know if it is in fact a
teratogen and the authors concluded
we can't say it's not we still don't
know that for sure but we certainly
can't find any evidence that it is
and that's their evidence that is berlin
skandagan's evidence that it is
a paper that finds that it's not okay so
that's number two number
three is the paper that they cite for
evidence of rare but serious
neurological adverse events
is the only one of these papers that
they appear to have cited correctly
but a closer reading shows that the
already extraordinarily rare events
nearly always occurred in people who
either had concomitant infections
um or were on other drugs at the same
time and therefore
we can't know we cannot know because
there were too many
confounding factors well it's not even
too many confounding factors
if the overwhelming majority of the
indicators that there is harm
are in people who have either these
profound infections or
are on other drugs then the point is you
can't say
that this drug is doing it right it is
at least a combinatoric
right right yeah it's at least a
combinatoric um
so
this this drug has been used so widely
so safely against so many things
and uh you know before we talk a little
bit about vaccine safety let's get to
um so the messaging okay we just get to
the messaging here
um it's been in use for decades it's
given to hundreds of millions of people
and it's being called
a veterinary veterinary deworming drug
by some people if you put on my screen
just briefly zach this is the
blog science-based medicine exploring
issues and controversies in science and
medicine
that sounds really sciency and
medicine-y to me given the name of the
blog and i can't imagine they would use
those words if they weren't doing those
things
but they then call ivermectin a
veterinary deworming drug
so please if my if i may zack a
veterinary deworming drug
now is it used in veterinary
circumstances to deworm
non-human animals thus making it
veterinary yes
yes it is does that make it a veterinary
deworming drug
no it in fact does not what is the
advantage of
framing this drug with decades and tens
of millions of doses
given safely and treating a wide variety
of this is a broad spectrum
drug right this this this drug has broad
spectrum of effects
and um among other things it
inhibits replication of the yellow fever
virus um
west nile dengue zika tick-borne
encephalitis west nile i already said
west nile west nile
is on the upsurge right now and now you
can't even get it
because people are scared of people
using it off label for kovid
and it could be useful it apparently is
useful against west nile which is
surging in several american states
and because because why because why
can't we get access to this
yeah the dewormer thing is particularly
good there's this picture of a vet
petting a horse that shows up every time
but it's a little bit like calling this
stuff
fire retardant right yeah i mean it's
used as a firearm that's exactly right
so just one one more thing here um
before
we either go to vaccine safety or
somewhere else um
off-label use of drugs is a
long-standing
practice for doctors right like this and
sometimes it doesn't work out and
sometimes it does
um but uh in the case of a drug with
such a safety record it's
extraordinary that it would be it would
be tamped down this much
and so i find a statement from okay so
it's granted a little bit obscure from
malaysia's national pharmaceutical
regulatory agency
okay that says any self-medicating or
off-label use of ivermectin could be
dangerous and it could distract from the
national covet-19 immunization program
that puts it within the realm of
possibility that the reason we're not
allowed to talk about
or get prescriptions for ivermectin for
uses prophylaxis against
kovid is not entirely a scientific
reason but also a political one yeah a
political one and no doubt these
conversations
sound very different on the inside um
but from the point of view of those of
us on the outside
who presumably every single one of us
even people who might have a conflict of
interest in their day job
every single one of us when we go home
to our families
presumably would love for sars kobe 2 to
be driven
to extinction and um i really
i cannot wrap my mind around why we are
not
producing this and distributing it
as a backup plan as a way to reach all
of the people that the vaccines won't
reach
as a way of treating breakthrough
infections whatever it may be
this tool the evidence for it is very
strong
and we are not deploying it in fact
we are in various places forbidden to
mention its utility
right so um all of this is sending a
blaring signal
something is wrong is it regulatory
capture that has leapt into the
public discussion space maybe it's
something else but whatever it is is
causing us to make a huge mistake
and uh for humanity to put itself in
jeopardy of
suffering from that mistake uh
indefinitely into the future
yep so uh berlinsky and dagon in their
quilt article fearmonger about the
safety of ivermectin
while giving uh the vaccines a pass and
i quote
the evidence that mrna based covet 19
vaccines are safe and that they work is
about as solid as medical evidence gets
sure no one can prove that in 10 years
time you won't suffer ill effects
but nor is there any reason to fear this
that's again them holding the two things
to very different
standards um that's a fairly human thing
to do to hold things to two different
standards but um doing so while
pretending to engage in dispassionate
analytical
argumentation is um i would say
analytical malpractice
actually well yeah the holding of the
two standards
is um ubiquitous in this landscape yeah
um and you know again it's
actually the same rhetorical trick
um and i'm sure this has a name and i'm
just not thinking of it but there's
something about
broadcasting the sense that only a fool
would accept such a thing
right the evidence for the safety of
these vaccines is about as good as
scientific evidence gets
well no it isn't we've got a signal in
the vares system
what does it mean we don't know we need
a proper analysis
of it um but the idea that the evidence
is as secure as scientific conclusions
get
nonsense um so the evidence is
noisy at best noisy at best is exactly
right
um in fact
oh my god um
we have here i can't find the paper so
i'm just going to have you zach show my
screen where i've i've got this on
in a word document so this is figure 10
from a paper that we'll be talking about
here
which yes is from is from the vares data
and there's been a lot of discussion
about how we can't trust the various
data because just
anyone can make a claim and also it's
really hard to use it's a super clunky
system
and um really hard to navigate and um
and who even knows what's hiding there
is the sort of argument
um but but this is this
is what we see um in vares as reports
per million doses
um tools along not not very
much until the roll out of the vaccines
and suddenly
we get a spike okay so zack if i may
thank you um that's that's a figure from
a mclaughlin at all
um who have written a it's a pre-print
at the moment that is it's a paper that
is
is due to enter the uh scientific
literature peer-reviewed pipeline but it
has not yet been peer-reviewed
which analyzes cobit 19 um
cover 19 vaccine reports in which the
people then
die and so it looks at this is this is
fairly preliminary they're looking at
just the first hundred first 250
reports in vares uh from the copen 19
vaccines
in which the people then then died and
so you know people
show up with symptoms deranging from you
know
who knows what there's a whole range of
symptoms that people are experiencing
from these things
um but before i specify what they found
i will say that an
additional thing these authors found and
they really did an extraordinary job
um is that conservatively at least 67
of the various reports from health
service employees and a further five
percent from pharmaceutical employees
um so that's um a conservative estimate
is close to three quarters at least
uh are from people within the health
service system that is not not rando's
entering data to try to create a false
signal
that's not that does not seem to be
what's going on
and that does suggest a certain level of
rigor in the various reports
so the meat of their findings are these
and i'll just read
this in spite of the fact that only 11
that is four percent
of the 250 present with a test confirmed
in current covet-19 infection
all 250 people in this collection were
reported as covet-19 deaths
this means that all even those who
received one or more negative test
results are erroneously counted in the
officially reported national covet 19
death tally so to put that in slightly
uh simpler english
you've got the first 250
vares reports from covet 19 vaccination
adverse events who then went on to die
a handful of these people actually had
an active covet infection and therefore
might well have been
breakthrough cases the vast majority of
them had negative tests or never had any
symptoms or had there is no reason to
think that they had coveted
they were after all vaccinated and we
are told that they are you know highly
effective these vaccinations
and yet not a single one of these 250
people who died
shortly after getting vaccinated having
had adverse events reported in the very
system
were recorded as vaccination-related
deaths they were all recorded as covet
deaths
if that is going on why are we supposed
to trust
any of the rest of the data that are
coming out this is an extraordinary
result
yeah now we should say we don't know
what it means obviously this is new to
all of us
and you know it would be fascinating if
there was some explanation but that does
sound like uh you know an extreme case
of what we've called monkeying with the
baseline
conservatively they say for 13 of the
250 deaths 5
a vaccine allergic reaction was quote
indisputably the most likely direct
cause for the symptoms and patient
outcomes described
super conservative number number there
right but
zero yeah zero of these 250 deaths are
attributed to vaccine
all of them are attributed to covid even
though a tiny handful of these people
had coveted
and they all had been vaccinated
recently and they all had had adverse
effects from the vaccines
that's one line of evidence that tells
us you know what
you guys are informing us that what was
what was berlinsky and
dagon's language again the evidence that
these vaccines are safe is about as
solid as medical evidence gets
really i'm afraid for medical evidence
then
so that's one then we also have uh
you want to add something yeah i do want
to add something actually zach could you
put up the other tweet of
dagins uh about um
the availability uh so this is a
tweet from may 15th where degen says
there is there is no existing antiviral
or any other intervention
that can greatly minimize deaths and so
this is with respect to copen in
particular yes yes
and so um the point is the double
standard that you are talking about
is it is a flashing neon sign here
the idea is no amount of evidence is
enough to suggest that we do have
repurposed drugs that work right right
and
no amount of evidence that there is a
signal
in the vares data that needs to be pay
attention paid attention to
is capable of of uh showing up on his
radar
so i don't know what accounts for that
but the
suggestion is that the conclusion is
where this all started
and that you know data will be
discounted or augmented
depending upon whether it goes in in
that direction yeah
um maybe i'll maybe i'll just do one
more of these here
okay let's just talk about bell's policy
a little bit
so bell's palsy is sudden onset weakness
in or freezing of muscles on one side of
the face you end up with
this this asymmetric facial structure it
tends to be temporary
um and there were four cases of bell's
palsy reported during phase two
three trials of the pfizer vaccine none
among the control group
and there's an fda briefing document
from december 10 2020
of the quote of the vaccines and related
biological products advisory committee
meeting
that was sponsored by pfizer and
bioentec in service of their new vaccine
and it was reported in this document on
page 38 again we'll link to it
that quote the observed frequency of
reported bell's palsy in the vaccine
group is consistent with the expected
background rate in the general
population and there is no clear basis
upon which to conclude a causal
relationship at this time
okay um i think i think you mentioned
bell's policy shortly
shortly after uh we began talking about
vaccines maybe in january or so
um but you know this is all we knew and
this is this is what we were told right
it turns out though that um the
conclusion
that there's no there's no basis on
which to imagine a causal relationship
is just it's wrong and there's a lot of
math that um
i'm not going to show here i'm not going
to go into here and the fda document
we'd have to be imagining what they did
because they don't they don't make any
justification they show none of their
math
they just say nah not a causal
relationship and
um it's it's in line with the expected
background rate for the population um
what seems to be the error that they
made and this is just impossible to
remember it
um is that they used annual estimates of
bell's palsy and these four
uh cases of bell's policy
post-vaccination were like days
three through forty-eight so you know
it's like a month and a half worth of
data and they compared that to an annual
an annual rate uh so in the lancet
uh on february 24th 2021 researchers
pointed out that there'd been an error
and they write the observed incidence of
bell's palsy in the vaccine arms is
between 3.5 and 7 times higher than
would be expected in the general
population
this finding signals a potential safety
phenomenon and suggests inaccurate
reporting of basic epidemiological
context to the public
that's concise incisive accurate
critically important right and they got
a little pushback
and they these same authors came back
again in the lancet on june 7th
and said in a longer piece the available
data remained consistent with a more
than threefold increase in risk for
bell's policy within one month of a
second vaccine
dose and this is again for the pfizer
vaccine
now reuters fact check we're well
familiar with the fact checkers at this
point aren't we writer's fact check on
whom everyone seems to be basing all of
their assurance that everything is just
dandy
uh was released on december 10 2020 the
same day as that fda document came out
and they use in fact the same language
they say quote
the frequency of bell's policy in the
vaccine group is consistent with the
expected background rate in the general
population
that was six months ago reuters has not
updated its fact check to relax to
reflect reality
they've made no changes they put that
out based on bad math from the fda or
pfizer or
someone over there and it has since been
reported not once but twice in the
lancet by researchers who are doing
relevant work here
that actually that number that
conclusion is dead wrong
you did the math wrong here's why you
it's
it's at least more than three times
maybe as much as seven times
the background rate of bell's palsy in
the general population
and if you go to reuters and
say is this true or is it not reuters is
still telling you no no no no no trust
us trust the fda we know better
and reuters is lying to you and the fda
is lying to you now the fda has
taken that language out of their later
their later manuscripts but writers
hasn't done a follow-up
warriors has not corrected this so and
this is the basis
that the scientifically enumerate and
illiterate journalists
are are looking to when they come to
conclusions and tell you that you're
lying
that's what fact checkers are supposed
to be doing and they're not doing their
job the fact checkers aren't being fact
checked
and they're not even trying to hold
themselves to any standards if you think
about
that uh long paragraph that you read
from
out of out of bounds yeah book
um the question about what is actually
going on here
and whether this is you know accidents
stacked on accidents or if this is a
mechanism for making a certain
conclusion
uh flow through a conversation that
would otherwise
be alarmed um you know we don't know but
um but that's the question is
has capture come to all of us is it
is it affecting our discussions with
each other yes
over social media and everywhere else
and you know what does it want because
what it is not doing is behaving in a
way that suggests that what it wants is
to drive this
pathogen to extinction and i would also
point out you and i have taken
a lot of flack over our position
uh on ivermectin that there is
encouraging evidence about it
and that it is a useful tool and it is
bizarre we are not using it
and that there is reason to be alarmed
about the signal in the varus data
about the vaccines but we have been
on this question since the beginning
right when people
were downplaying the severity
of covet 19 we were saying no no no
you are being misled by the fact that
the case fatality
rate is comparatively low the damage
this is doing to people is huge and
there's a clock ticking
right we have a an evolving pathogen
that is going to learn
to resist our attempts to drive it to
extinction we have a
this is i think hard for people to grasp
but
we at the moment are dealing with a
naive pathogen it has not yet
learned to stick to us so well that we
can't get rid of it the way we can't get
rid of influenza
right but if we give it enough chance
because we play around
and we play these games where we don't
use the best tools at our disposal
because maybe that
you know isn't in the best uh financial
interests of shareholders of this
corporation or that corporation
we may get stuck with this thing
permanently in fact i would say it is
likely
now in light of that i would argue
whatever it is that is the best plan
to drive this thing to extinction that
ought to be our plan
and i think you and i have been very
clear i do not hear this point
made widely if anywhere else the
tool is composite right you've got part
of the population that's immune
from having had covet 19. that immunity
is good because it is likely to be broad
right you've got part of the population
that is
mostly immune because they've been
vaccinated and for that part of the
human population all
almost 8 billion of us that has not been
vaccinated and hasn't had covid
we need to get them something that will
prevent them from coming down with it
that's the way we get over the threshold
number that allows us
to bring r naught which then becomes r
sub f
down below one so that the thing
actually goes to extinction and you know
every time you see one of these curves
where the thing
has spiked and then it begins to drop
that's because
r sub f has gone below one that's the
key you get it below
one it will go extinct given time you
get it way below one it'll go extinct
quickly
that ought to be what we're doing that's
the conversation we do not seem to be
having and we need to get there right
away
absolutely um well
there's a lot more to say but should we
should we pivot and
do a little bit from the book and uh
let's do it let's do it okay
um so again we will we will put
something out in writing we're not sure
where yet
um hopefully hopefully very soon um that
will be a
you know a companion to this both both
will stand alone
um but let me see what am i what am i
doing again
we are gonna read an excerpt i'm gonna
read an excerpt from chapter four
uh again the chapter called medicine and
specifically
from a section called
considering the risks of reductionism as
we choose what to put in our bodies
long-time loyal listeners
we'll remember that in our very first
live stream on march something
2020 um we said that we had just that
month
submitted the first draft of of this
book this book being a hunter-gatherer's
guide to the 21st century
this book being a hunter-gatherer's
guide to the 21st century book we've
been talking about writing for
over a decade and it's it's it's written
now and it'll be out in september of
this year
um and uh the first draft uh
has changed the final draft has changed
a lot from the first draft but very
little in this chapter
has uh and so um you know this was
written
before kovid largely there's there's one
section not in what i'm going to read
which we actually did go back in and and
just add a paragraph
because we were doing all the revisions
during covet but um
recognize that we wrote this based on
our lifetime of thinking evolutionarily
not within the context of a pandemic
with this with this novel virus or these
novel
so considering the risks of reductionism
as we choose what to put in our bodies
is vanillin is vanillin the same as
vanilla
is thc identical to marijuana no
in both cases a single molecule active
important in the human experience
of the larger thing vanilla or pot is
not representative of the whole
in the case of vanillin the effect
appears to have culinary ramifications
only
foods flavored with vanillin do not have
the full richness of vanilla in the case
of thc which has long been understood to
be the main psychoactive constituent of
cannabis
breeding only for that molecule made
plants that would certainly get you high
but they had insufficient antipsychotic
tempering effects from cbd another
active molecule in pot
oops and as of this writing there is a
new marijuana molecule getting traction
about the scientific literature in the
pot-breeding community
cbg it is being purported to have
benefits even greater than those of cbd
maybe but it is the human discovery of
that molecule that is elevated to the
status of being studied
it was there all along but now we've
imbued it with mystical qualities
our discovery of it changes nothing
about what it does we often mistake an
effect
for instance of an action a treatment or
a molecule for our understanding of the
effect
what a thing does and what we think or
know that it does or not the same thing
a combination of hubris and technical
capacity has humans recreating this
error over and over again
from fluoridated drinking water to
shelf-stable foods with unintended
consequences
from the myriad issues with sun exposure
to whether gmos are safe we are
constantly seduced by reductionist
thinking
led astray by the fantasy of simplicity
where the truth is complex
reductionism particularly with respect
to our bodies and minds is harming us
sometimes it is even killing us
early in the 20th century fluoride was
discovered to be correlated with fewer
cavities
so fluoride was put into many municipal
water supplies to decrease tooth decay
the fluoride in drinking water is a
byproduct of industrial processes though
not a molecular form that appears in
nature or has ever been part of our diet
that's one point against it furthermore
we find neurotoxicity in children who
are exposed to fluoridated drinking
water
a correlation between hypothyroidism and
fluoridated water
and in salmon a loss of the ability to
navigate back to their home stream after
swimming in fluoridated water
is florid a magic bullet for reducing
cavities with no cost to other aspects
of health
seems not more to the point the quest
for magic bullets for simple answers
that are universally applicable to all
humans in all conditions
is misguided if it were that easy
selection would almost certainly have
found a way
think you find a solution that is too
good to be true look hard for the hidden
costs
remember chesterton's fence and i'm
going to skip over our discussion
of the shelf stability of processed
foods and the discussion of vitamin d
just so that we have a slightly shorter
excerpt here and move into um
and also about sunscreen and move here
given this track record of reduction of
science and health advice should we
trust that gmos are safe just because
those who would profit from their
acceptance either intellectually or
financially tell us they are
we suggest not are some gmos safe
almost certainly are all gmos safe
almost certainly not
how will we know which are which and can
we rely on those who have created them
to be vigilant on our behalf
until we know the answer to those last
questions the precautionary principle
suggests steering clear
finally it is worth noting that some of
the major successes of western medicine
surgery antibiotics and vaccines are
firmly reduced
rooted in a reductionist tradition and
have saved millions of lives
the problem we are highlighting is the
over-application of a reductionist
approach
the germ theory of disease in its
simplest formulation the recognition
that pathogens cause much disease
led to the discovery and formulation of
antibiotics a huge health boost for
humanity
then we over-generalized and imagined
that all microbes are bad for us
we are now coming to realize that our
microbiome has evolved with us and is
necessary for healthy gastrointestinal
tract
antibiotics are one of relatively few
powerhouse tools of western medicine but
as they have been overprescribed we have
seen an attendant rise in people
becoming sick
often chronically so just as people are
falling ill from lacking healthy
microbiomes due to over prescription of
antibiotics
so too are our livestock furthermore
there are unintended side effects of
many antibiotics that will be shocking
to most people
my personal experience with the
unintended consequences of antibiotics
was a ruptured achilles tendon
it's now understood that tendon and
ligament injury is one side effect of
cipro and all of the antibiotics in that
class the fluoroquinolones
which um which i took in quantity in the
1990s to ward off gi bugs while
conducting research in the tropics
from fluoridated drinking water to
antifungals and shelf-stable food from
sunscreen to the overuse of antibiotics
over and over we make the same kinds of
mistakes combine reductionism with a
tendency to over-generalize
in a hyper-novel world where quick but
expensive and potentially dangerous
fixes are common
and we've explained some of the major
areas of modern health and medicine
this is exactly what we're wrestling
with here it's not going to be simple
and if someone is telling you i've got
the simple magic bullet and it's going
to allow you to get back to your life
and you're going to go out and be able
to have cocktails with your friends
without worrying ever again about covid
they probably are trying to sell you
something that isn't exactly like what
is in the package that they've got for
you yeah
there are two things going on one is
the tendency to over generalize from
reductionism and the other has to do
with perverse incentives and they're
both captured there i mean i remember
the world
that you and i grew up in was a world
that did regard
microbes as hostile yeah even though
microbes all everywhere well that's
exactly i mean i don't think either
actually in either of our homes but in
in many many homes lysol was probably
probably in my my natal home i i at
least can tell you what it smells like
so
yeah um so it was there but
yes the sense that what one was trying
to do was to drive
microbes to zero is a preposterous
it's impossible it would be deadly
and the point is it misses the basic
point which is that the occasional
microbe
is uh dangerous and most microbes are
harmless and some microbes are essential
and you know welcome to complex systems
yeah that's right that is right
uh well are we there i believe we are
there okay um amir
well my friend amir okay um my
my computer has chosen this moment to
make me this may actually have been its
final oh no
it came back again it's not dead yet
unfortunately
um that was almost two hours so we are
going to
take a break and we will come back with
a q a because we told you we would and
you can ask
questions at that um
uh boy where even is it it's um
thank you dark horse
[Music]
darkhorsesubmissions.com you can ask
questions but we're going to do an
abbreviated q a
this week because we started late and we
bet we've been at this a long time
so we'll just finish with a few um a few
of
the typical announcements um please
consider joining
either both of us at our patreons we've
seen an
outpouring of support uh since our
youtube channel got demonetized
and we are extraordinarily grateful we
really really truly appreciate it
and um and it empowers us to keep
fighting it really does
yeah it really does uh we do have some
things like that goliath shirt that we
introduced uh
last live stream at darkhorsepodcat no
store.darkhorsepodcast.org
you can send uh logistical questions
like i want to send them something
or what was the url on that again um to
darkhorse.moderator
gmail.com uh no don't send
uh the questions for the q a there they
will they will not get
forwarded to us um consider subscribing
to again
all all four of our channels the two on
youtube the main one brett weinstein
and darkhorse podcast clips and and here
i hope on odyssey
um brett weinstein and darquez podcast
clips like this material
share it and um remember to
be good to the ones you love and eat
good food and get outside
be well everyone
[Music]
you